diese woche anders genannt eigentlich
sollten sie dahin und so meine damen und
herren nach der video konferenz der
bundeskanzlerin mit den regierungschefs
und regierungschefin der länder
informieren sie jetzt über die
beschlüsse bundeskanzlerin
ministerpräsident söder der erste
bürgermeister tschentscher und
vizekanzler und finanzminister olaf
scholz ja meine damen und herren wir
haben in den letzten tagen sehr intensiv
uns beschäftigt mit unserer heutigen
zusammenkunft und wir haben heute
miteinander beraten per video-konferenz
wo steht unser land im blick auf die
epidemie die von dem corona virus
ausgeht
und ich möchte mich bei den
bundesländern bedanken dass wir die
gemeinsame linie die wir beschlossen
haben auch durchgesetzt haben und dass
wir uns heute verabredet haben auch die
nächste phase gemeinsam dann zu
gestalten was hat uns heute geleitet als
erstes möchte ich allen menschen in
deutschland noch einmal ganz herzlich
danken den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
ihr leben verändert haben die verzichtet
haben auf kontakte die sich einschränken
nicht weil sie der regierung etwa in
gefallen tun sondern weil sie ihren
mitmenschen helfen wollen und das ist
etwas ganz ganz starkes und wichtiges
was unser land bei aller einschränkungen
im augenblick erlebt und es zeigt dass
wenn etwas wirklich gutes entstehen soll
in unserem land in deutschland dann ist
das mit den bürgern und durch die bürger
geschehen und dafür bin ich dankbar
wir haben etwas erreicht das haben uns
heute auch das robert koch institut
bestätigt und wir haben etwas erreicht
was ja keineswegs von anfang an sicher
war nämlich dass unsere ärzte unsere
pflegekräfte alle die im medizinischen
bereich in den krankenhäusern arbeiten
nicht überfordert wurden sie leisten
enormes und viele sind auch unter
größter anspannung tätig aber ist
ist so gewesen dass unser
gesundheitssystem am laufen gehalten
werden konnte und ich möchte mich ganz
herzlich bei allen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern in dem gesundheitlichen
bereich inklusive der niedergelassenen
ärzte und der vielen menschen die in
diesem bereich arbeiten genauso in den
seniorenheimen und ähnlichen
einrichtungen ganz herzlich bedanken
und ich denke natürlich in dieser stunde
auch an die infizierten die die korona
krankheit erleben oder schon erlebt
haben und wir wissen ja auch dass wir
leider auch schon eine vielzahl von
opfern zu beklagen hatten
was er der erreicht haben das ist ein
zwischenerfolg nicht mehr und nicht
weniger
und ich betone es ist ein zerbrechlicher
zwischenerfolg das hat herr wieder vom
robert-koch-institut uns heute noch
einmal gesagt wir haben die faktoren die
dafür einen aussage treffen in eine gute
richtung entwickelt aber wir haben auch
nicht viel spielraum sondern wir müssen
jetzt ganz konzentriert weitermachen
deshalb hat unsere beratungen bestimmt
das ist jetzt kein falsches vorpreschen
geben darf auch wenn die besten
absichten dahinter stehen sondern wir
müssen verstehen dass wir so lange mit
dem virus leben müssen wie es keine
medikamente und insbesondere keinen
impfstoff gibt und wir müssen die
erfolge sichern sie wir erreicht haben
und deshalb ist es sozusagen wenn wir
darüber sprechen welche schritte in
richtung einer eines etwas mehr zulassen
von öffentlichen leben die wir ja alle
gehen wollen gehen dann müssen wir sagen
es ist geht um äußerste vorsicht die
arbeiten lassen müssen und das hat
unsere beratung heute auch geprägt denn
es geht jedes mal um menschen
wir haben uns geeinigt dass wir
natürlich ausgehend von unseren
beschlüssen die wir am 12
16 und 22 jahr 2020 gefasst haben und
dass es auch weiter entscheidend bleibt
dass bürgerinnen und bürger in der
öffentlichkeit ein mindestabstand von
1,5 metern einhalten
und sich dort nur alleine mit einer
weiteren nicht im haushalt lebenden
personen oder im an kreis der
angehörigen des eigenen hausstandes
aufhalten
das gilt weiterhin und die verstöße
dagegen werden auch weiter von den
ordnungsbehörden geahndet um zukünftig
infektionsketten schnell zu erkennen ist
mir etwas ganz wichtig und ich bedanke
mich bei den ländern die auch zum großen
teil ihre gesundheitsbehörden schon
aufgestockt haben wenn wir jetzt mehr
öffentliches leben zu lassen in kleinen
schritten dann ist es ganz wichtig dass
wir noch besser die infektionsketten
verfolgen können es muss unser ziel sein
jede infektionskette verfolgen zu können
dafür werden wir arbeiten wir auch an
einer app aber vor allen dingen ist es
die aufgabe der gesundheitsbehörden denn
wenn wir das können dann können wir auch
infektionsherde eingrenzen und dann ist
die leckere lockerung im bereich des
öffentlichen lebens nicht mehr so
gravierend weil wir ja wissen wo
entstehen infektionsherde wenn wir das
nicht haben dann werden wir nicht so
erfolgreich sein und deshalb ist das von
ganz ganz entscheidender bedeutung
wir wollen natürlich eine gute
versorgung mit test kapazitäten wir
wollen an der medizinischen
schutzausrüstung arbeiten die haben wir
sehr ausführlich über die frage der
sogenannten alltags masken gesprochen
und sprechen uns dafür aus dass es
empfehlenswert ist dass es geboten ist
sozusagen diese alltags masken auch zu
verwenden im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und in beim einkaufen
ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger punkt
der jetzt auch weiterentwickelt wurde in
unseren beschlüssen wir werden also in
bürgerinnen und bürgern die nutzung
entsprechender alltags masten
insbesondere im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und beim einkauf
dringend empfehlen wir glauben dass wir
in mit jedem tag jetzt mehr diese
alltags masken bekommen werden und dass
das dann auch dazu dienen sollte andere
menschen
zu schützen und wenn es viele tun dann
eben auch sich selbst zu schützen
wir haben immer pflegeheime gesprochen
hier wird es ganz wichtig sein dass wir
uns altenheime dass wir individuelle
konzepte entwickeln um nicht die soziale
isolation der menschen in diesen heimen
zu haben und trotzdem die
sicherheitsstandards einzuhalten
und wir haben natürlich eine
ausführliche diskussion über
kindergärten schulen und hochschulen
geführt und ich weiß wie viele menschen
in deutschland gerade diese diskussion
verfolgen denn es ist natürlich eine
ganz ganz schwierige situation für
eltern dass ihre kinder nicht andere
freunde treffen können dass es nur eine
notbetreuung gibt dass die allermeisten
zu hause sind und trotzdem müssen wir um
die anforderungen auch an den
infektionsschutz einzuhalten um
menschenleben zu sichern wir ganz gut
sein ganz schrittweise vorgehen
das ist uns heute auch gelungen indem
wir uns vor allen dingen erst einmal auf
die abschlussklassen die prüfung machen
müssen konzentrieren
in einem nächsten schritt auf die dann
prüfung machen oder schulwechsel vor
sich haben und dass die
kultusministerkonferenz uns dann nochmal
ein ausführliches konzept vorlegt
genauso wie die jugend ministerkonferenz
denn wir können nur schrittweise dann
nach dem 4
langsam wieder die einzelnen schulen
dinge machen es muss in reduzierten
gruppen seien es muss ein schulbus
konzept da sein es muss ein pausen
konzept da sein das wird also eine hohe
logistische aufwand zu betreiben seien
und deshalb bedarf es einer intensiven
vorbereitung und ich weiß wie viel
verzicht das noch für eltern bedeutet
aber ich glaube es ist einfach notwendig
wenn wir sagen wir müssen in der
pandemie mit diesem virus leben und das
deutet sich dort auch an der betriebe
müssen auch hygiene konzepte anfertigen
und werden dann ab vierten mal ihre
arbeit wieder aufnehmen können wenn die
schutzmaßnahmen ausreichend sind wir
haben intensiv über das hohe gut der
religionsfreiheit gesprochen und auch
über die veranstaltung die natürlich bei
den von den kirchen stattfinden ich
möchte den kirchen ein ganz herzliches
dankeschön sagen denn sie haben gerade
jetzt über ostern viel fantasie
und das obwohl keine gottesdienste
stattfinden konnten menschen auch ihren
glauben leben konnten wir wollen dass
religiöse feierlichkeiten
veranstaltungen und zusammenkünfte
anderer glaubensgemeinschaften zunächst
weiter nicht stattfinden aber es wird
noch in dieser woche ein gespräch von
ministerpräsidenten und dem
bundesministerium des innern geben über
die frage wie man einen einvernehmlichen
weg für das weitere vorgehen findet
wichtig ist dass wir das wirtschaftliche
die wirtschaftliche tätigkeit im großen
ganzen ja nicht unterbunden haben
sondern nur dort wo es publikumsverkehr
gibt hier haben wir uns natürlich sehr
ausführlich mit der frage der eröffnung
weiterer geschäfte fast hier haben wir
auf der einen seite gesagt es können
geschäfte bis zu 800 quadratmetern auf
machen allerdings mit guten konzepten
für die nutzung dieser kunst und dieser
geschäfte mit hygiene konzepten und wir
müssen auch schauen dass nicht sozusagen
auf den straßen sich riesige schlangen
bilden auch das gehört zum
verantwortungsbereich und das wollen der
werden auch eine vielzahl von vorarbeit
vorbereitungsarbeiten geführt werden
müssen
wir werden viel in die forschung
investieren das ist unstrittig um gerade
auch unseren teil dazu zu leisten
noch mehr zu erforschen was wie viele
menschen hatten diese infektion schon
was wir können wir beitragen zu einem
impfstoff entwicklung welche medikamente
sind wichtig und ich darf sagen dass wir
auch gerade seitens des bundesheer ein
sehr großzügiger finanzieller
unterstützung alles tun damit der
forschungsstandort deutschland auch sein
beitrag zur bewältigung dieser pandemie
leisten kann abschließend
wir werden uns immerhin 14 tages
abstimmen mit dem weiteren entwicklungen
befassen wir wollen sehen welche
auswirkungen haben die lockerungs
möglichkeit lieber heute ins auge
gefasst haben auf die
entwicklung der infektion und in diesem
sinne ist es uns deshalb werden wir uns
deshalb am 30 april wieder darüber
unterhalten was passiert dann nach dem
dritten mai die spanne die wir jetzt ins
auge gefasst haben ist sie zwischen dem
20 april und den dritten und dann werden
wir in weiteren schritten vorgehen und
es wird jetzt ganz davon abhängen wie
entwickeln sich die infektionsraten ich
sagte schon wir haben nicht viele
spielräume und deshalb hoffe ich dass
alle weiter so mitmachen und die regeln
einhalten das alles ermöglicht uns dann
ein kleines stück immer weiter
öffentliches leben wie wir es gewohnt
sind aber eben in der pandemie
das heißt anders und mit anderen regeln
ja wenn ich so herrn söder
ich habe heute sehr viele damen und
herren vor bundeskanzler erst mal ich
glaube das war eine sehr sehr gute sehr
wichtig und sehr verantwortungsbewusste
diskussion die wir geführt haben
die war geprägt von dem tiefen
bewusstsein baby unser land und die
menschen weiter schützen können
eines kann man glaube ich sagen
deutschland ist bislang im vergleich zu
vielen anderen ländern besser durch
diese schlimme krise die global
stattfindet gekommen
wir können schon sagen dass wir corona
zumindest anders unter kontrolle haben
als in vielen anderen ländern der welt
warum weil die strategie die wir
entwickelt haben die richtige war
rechtzeitig frühzeitig zu handeln und
konsequent zu bleiben
deswegen ist wichtig dass wir diesen
grundlegenden weg fortsetzen
ich freue mich heute dass wir weiter
einen vorsichtigen weg beschritten haben
wir haben keine unkontrollierten exit
strategien diskutiert sondern wir setzen
weiter auf vorsicht auf vorsicht denn
wir glauben dass die größte gefahr
bestehen könnte dass die guten zahlen
was heißt guten zahlen also die
entwicklung die stabiles dass die einen
rückschlag erleidet wenn wir zu viel
riskieren wenn wir leichtsinnig werden
und wenn wir normalität vortäuschen dies
noch nicht geben kann solange es keinen
impfstoff solange es keine medikamente
gibt solange müssen wir einen weg ein
konzept finden mit corona zu leben in
form von so viel sicherheit wie
möglich aber auch die möglichkeiten der
freiheit den menschen wieder zu geben
vor dem hintergrund haben wir die
unterschiedlichsten bereiche diskutiert
miteinander gewogen wir an spielräume
entwickelt war natürlich länder
unterschiedlich betroffen sind süden
deutschlands ist stärker betroffen mit
infektion als andere teile von
deutschlands insofern haben die auch
rahmen definiert die unterschiedlich
ausgeschöpft werden können
beispielsweise für mein land kann ich
sagen wir werden das vorsichtiger
angehen und etwas zurückhaltend angehen
aber die möglichkeiten sind auch je nach
der infektion slave stärker zu gewichten
wichtig ist vorsicht besonnenheit ist an
der stelle wichtig als überstürztes
vorgehen was uns in einigen wochen zu
einem ergebnis führen könnte dass die
zahlen sich schlechter entwickeln und
wir dann zurück drehen müssen denn über
eines darf sich keiner täuschen
die gute entwicklung hängt mit den
maßnahmen zusammen getroffen worden
auch länder die anfangs anders gedacht
haben sind letztlich den weg in
deutschland geht nahezu vollständig
gefolgt einige später einige unter
schmerzen dass wir glaube ich sollte in
deutschland nicht vergessen dass es ganz
anders aussehen könnte hätten wir falsch
zu spät oder nicht umsichtig reagiert
wir wollen uns jetzt nicht durch die
gegend tasten sondern wollen mit
versuchen mit weitblick und übersicht
durch diese weitere krise zu führen
deswegen ist wichtig dass wir in
schritten arbeiten und schauen wie die
schritte wirken nicht nur was die
schritte an normalität bedeuten sondern
vor allem was bedeuten die schritte auch
in der entwicklung der infektionen und
deswegen nicht alles auf einmal sondern
abgestuft zeitversetzt bestimmte
bereiche einfacher bestimmte bereiche
deutlich zurückhaltender
die philosophie muss lauten fortsetzen
der strategie erleichtern womöglich ist
das aber mit schutz versehen ihr der
leistung mit schutz versehen und wichtig
die vorsorge intensiv ausbauen aufbauen
das ist das erste und vielleicht auch
nach wie vor die wichtigste botschaft
die distanz geburt ausgangs
beschränkungen oder kontakt kann wie
immer dezent die bleiben erhalten
geschäfte werden leicht und schrittweise
geöffnet
aber mit schutzkonzepte schutzkonzepte
heißen infektions schützende bereiche zu
machen desinfektion abstand zu halten
auch bestimmte 2020 auf 20 quadratmeter
eine person zu nehmen
und deswegen genau den bereich auf der
masken in den vordergrund zu rücken
uns ist klar der staat sorgt was die
masten struktur betrifft für
medizinische masken um den pflege in
altenheimen in krankenhäusern und ärzten
die hochwertigen ganz besonders auch
schwierig herzustellende masken
sicherzustellen
das ist aufgabe des staates aber bei
geschäften und im privaten und im pv
bereich ist es wichtig dass man auch mit
einfachen community masken mit einem
entsprechenden mund und nasenschutz
entsprechend auch selbstständig erklären
kann deswegen ja bei geschäften gibt es
eine eine leichte öffnung wir im süden
das war etwas zeitversetzt machen aber
es gibt diese öffnung bis maximal 800
quadratmeter auch da ist unterschiedlich
wäre das ausschöpfen
es muss eben der jeweiligen struktur
entsprechend auch verantwortet werden
ich halte es aber für richtig dass wir
diese form machen aber immer noch einmal
mit hygiene konzept deswegen kann man
das auch nicht gleich machen war gerade
kleinere geschäfte brauchen ein
stückweit zeit um die umsetzung zu
machen auch da gilt der grundsatz
langsamer bringt mehr erfolg als
hektisch und überstürzt auch für die
wirtschaft klar ist dass gastronomie
hotel für tourismus bars discos
kaufhäuser shopping malls also alles das
muss sich ändern viele menschen
ansammeln nach wie vor nicht geöffnet
werden können
wir werden im nächsten wochen dann
entscheiden wie aber dass wir
zurückhaltend sind können sie daran
sehen dass wir großveranstaltungen bis
ende august bereits klar gesagt haben
das geht nicht
also alles was an bier festen an
großveranstaltungen ist werden auf
keinen fall stattfinden können denn bis
dahin haben wir weder medikamente noch
im stoff und wir haben gesehen dass der
après ski in ischgl dass der karneval in
heinsberg oder stark wir bei unseren
tirschenreuth das waren ja leider
plattformen in eine starke und auch
schlimme ausbreitung möglich gewesen ist
deswegen da große zurückhaltung was die
glaubensgemeinschaft mit dürfte die
bundeskanzlers zu recht gesagt wir
schätzen dass guter glaubensfreiheit
enorm und es hat jeden geschmack
er ist an ostern zu sehen bewundernswert
übrigens auch beispielsweise wieder der
heilige vater papst diesem es ja auch in
einem sehr starke beutel ahnt wie in
italien ist ganze gemacht hat da wird
über konzepte nachgedacht wie wir das
vernünftig miteinander machen können zu
schulen
bei schulen das sind wir uns einig und
da bin ich sehr sehr dankbar dass wir da
keine falschen entscheidung getroffen
haben und irgendwie ab nächster woche
alles öffnen denn auch unsere
lehrerverbände den ich an der stelle ein
großes dankeschön sagen möchte die
lehrerin lehrerverbände in deutschland
machen sich wirklich gute gedanken wie
wir den schulbetrieb klug machen können
auch die kmk aber den bereits für uns
ist wichtig dass er für die länder ganz
entscheidend weil sie auch
unterschiedliche zeit zyklen mit abitur
prüfungen mit ferien zunächst mal dass
man die vorbereitung trifft das abitur
prüfung und beispielsweise oder mittlere
reife oder quali stattfinden können das
ist der erste schritt dann erst mit
einer zeitversetzt haid das ist dann ab
würden wir sind bayern machen ab vierten
mal das andere dann über
abschlussklassen zu reden und andere
dinge wie grundschule kita bleiben
vorerst allerdings versehen mit
notfallbetreuung auszuweiten
denn wenn wir bestimmte geschäfte öffnen
brauchen wir ja auch eine entsprechende
bessere betreuung da haben sich die
länder verpflichtet das an der stelle zu
machen und die kultusminister müssen
sich dann mit den fragen noch einmal
beschäftigen wie wir bei mehr schülern
in der schule das zu organisieren dass
abstand gehalten werden kann
welche fächer unterrichtet werden müssen
wie man auch mit versetzungen umgeht was
ganz wichtig ist denn vielen schülern
viel zeit um sozusagen in der kritischen
phase eine versetzung zu schaffen
andere wären froh wenn es dann schon zu
ende gewesen weil das schuljahr das
müssen wir sehr klug überlegen da
brauchen wir sehr seriöse konzepte damit
die für alle mittel treten können
aber noch mal wichtig bei grundschulen
und kitas wir bleiben vorerst die soft
ist der denkbar vierte klasse also
übertritt bleiben erst einmal
geschlossen
wir glauben einfach dass man auch den
kleinen kindern nicht zumuten kann
mit mundschutz und ähnlichem zu leben
oder zu arbeiten und da ist es auch sehr
schwer zu appellieren jetzt zu sagen
verhaltet euch mal entsprechend so wie
schon manche erwachsene sich schwer tun
was das thema mundschutz betrifft geht
natürlich übrigens auch für den öpnv
ich glaube dass wir im öpnv dass wir in
bereichen auch der geschäfte die jetzt
sich weiterentwickeln in der öffnung
dass wir da er stärker dieses masken die
brut verstehen müssen
und auch da stärker daran erinnern
müssen denn all die bereiche wo man kurz
auch zusammen ist sehr nahen oder
abstand schwerer zu halten ist da ist
eine maske
da ist ein mundschutz ein ganz einfacher
übrigens und nasenschutz ein hilfreiches
instrument des ordens zu bringen
letzter punkt strategie fortsetzen
erleichterungen machen und vorsorge
verstärkt unser ziel ist ja wenn es
optimal lief in so einer phase wie bei
webasto zu kommen dass wir die
einzelfällen infektionsketten gut
verfolgen konnten
das drama in italien war ja dass
infektionsketten nicht mehr verfolgbar
waren und damit völlig unkontrollierte
ausbreitung da war das gelingt uns aber
nur wenn wir neben der erhöhung der
intensivbetten weiter und ich glaube man
kann jetzt eigentlich sagen das deutsche
gesundheitssystem
bei aller kritik die es immer geht hat
den internationalen bewährungstest im
moment gut bestanden
es kann wirklich sagen und wir gehen
eher höher
wir sagen wir wollen eher näher machen
wir brauchen mehr in den städten mehr
medizinische versorgung
wir brauchen ganz wichtig mehr test
kapazitäten die müssen wir deutlich
ausweiten
bei uns beispielsweise wird es sind
wirklich sehr sehr viel und wir wollen
die test kapazität noch einmal massiv
ausbauen
weil nur über tests wird die gesamte
datenlage und auch die verfolgung von
infektionsketten gewinnen können und
lasten und liest wir brauchen auch den
ausbau der gesundheitsämter bei uns wenn
es 4000 personen sein die wir zusätzlich
bilden also insgesamt 650 teams allein
in bayern die die jeweilige
rückverfolgung und auch beobachtung und
entsprechende beachtung der
infektionskette machen können fazit ich
bin im bund sehr dankbar der bund hat
heute sehr mitgeholfen dass auch aus
unterschiedlichen positionen der länder
am ende ein gemeinschaftlicher geist
weiter herrscht das ist glaube ich ganz
wichtig also deutschland hat eine
gemeinschaftliche philosophie
und auch die debatten der letzten tage
glaube ich sind jetzt heute in ein gutes
ergebnis gemündet dass verlässlichkeit
vergleichbarkeit und großen ganzen sehr
einheitlicher rahmen
in ganz deutschland gibt es gab schon
ein paar kleine unterschiede die sind
aber nicht schlimm die bleiben auch mal
eine woche hin oder her aber im großen
und ganzen sind alle länder sich mit dem
bund komplett einig in der strategie und
die strategie heißt vorsicht heißt da
wir sind noch nicht über den berg aber
wenn wir diese geduld die wir haben
weiter klug umsetzen dann glaube ich
werden wir am ende vielleicht sogar aus
dieser ganzen situation gestärkt
hervorgehen können als es viele viele
andere länder der welt schaffen können
peter herr bürgermeister tschentscher ja
sehr geehrte damen und herren als wir
vor einigen wochen erkannt haben dass
deutschland doch sehr stark von der
korona pandemie ergriffen wird haben die
bundes- und die landesregierung ja keine
vollbremsung gemacht aber fast wir haben
in sehr kurzer zeit mit sehr geringen
zeitlichen und inhaltlichen
unterschieden
das öffentliche leben weitgehend
zurückgefahren
wir haben die öffentliche bewegungen
eingeschränkt wir haben alles gemacht
was wir unbedingt machen mussten um uns
überhaupt zu orientieren und sicheren
boden unter die füße zu bekommen in
dieser doch sehr schwierigen situation
wo wir nicht riskieren wollten bilder
die wir aus italien aus spanien aus
frankreich vor augen hatten hier in
deutschland zu riskieren und die gute
nachricht heute ist wir haben das
infektionsgeschehen dadurch sehr sehr
stark verlangsamt die kritische
nachricht ist wir haben nicht viel
spielraum
das eis ist dünn wir müssen bei allem
was wir tun denken dass der erfolg der
bisherigen maßnahmen nicht in frage
gestellt wird
zugleich ist uns bewusst geworden in den
letzten wochen dass es ist wie mit der
luft anhalten
die ersten zehn sekunden sind noch
leicht die nächsten zehn sekunden werden
schwieriger und nach weiteren sekunden
spürt man plötzlich wie stark auch die
folgewirkung sind die wirtschaftlichen
vorgeworfen die sozialen folgen
die psychologischen fragen die
auswirkungen im bildungssystem und
deswegen war heute die diskussion
geprägt davon dass wir an den
wichtigsten stellen die erleichterungen
jetzt von den beschränkungen so
formulieren dass wir diese beschränkung
mit maß und im blick auf die wirkung
sehr sehr dosiert lockern
und immer wenn so der impuls werk von
jemandem mensch eigentlich müssten wir
doch stärker in die normalität zurück
man war immer dieses verantwortungsvolle
im hintergrund das könnte ein zu großer
schritt sein wir dürfen nicht in den
einzelnen bereichen zu viel riskieren
und damit den gesamterfolg infrage
stellen und in dieser doch wirklich ganz
gemeinsamen haltung sind wir durch die
themen durch die maßnahmenpakete
gegangen die vorbereitet sind und haben
hier wirklich einen verantwortungsvollen
einen maßvollen schritt jetzt vereinbart
einerseits mit weiteren mit
erleichterungen die jetzt auch nötig
sind und die maßvoll sind andererseits
aber auch mit maßnahmen die vereinbart
werden um das infektionsgeschehen noch
besser in den griff zu bekommen
die korona test kapazitäten sollen
vergrößert werden
das öffentliche gesundheitswesen muss
gestärkt werden die das tracing von von
kontakten soll ausgearbeitet werden
wir müssen uns über einen längeren
zeitraum in dieser situation darauf
einstellen dass wir mit der pandemie zu
tun haben auch das ist eine klare
botschaft heute der gesundheits experten
des robert-koch-instituts wir werden
über monate noch mit solchen
einschränkungen leben müssen und
deswegen müssen wir auch prüfen wie wir
am besten durch diese schwierigen monate
kommen und das was heute vereinbart ist
hier sind die wichtigsten maßnahmen die
wir jetzt umsetzen wollen
wir werden das kontrollieren es muss
über die nächsten monate immer wieder
nötig seien und und wichtig wird es sein
dass wir kontrollieren wie sich die
dinge die wir tun die wir umsetzen die
vorkehrungen die wir treffen die die
sich im wirklichen infektionsgeschehen
auswirken denn es bleibt nach wie vor
das oberste ziel
dass wir gesundheit und menschenleben
schützen unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überlasten und damit eben etwas tun was
wir wirklich als breites bewusstsein in
der bevölkerung auch wahrnehmen dass das
ein gemeinsames ziel ist es ihr
gemeinsam unsere eigene gesundheit aber
eben auch das gemeinwesen schützen wenn
wir mit der gleichen disziplin jetzt
weiter vorangehen wie wir das in den
letzten wochen erlebt haben herr
minister scholz
die welt hat sich für uns alle geändert
angesichts an der weltweiten pandemie
die alle menschen auf der welt
gleichermaßen trifft aber die länder
ganz unterschiedlich deutschland hat
große heraus möglichkeiten mit dieser
herausforderung zurechtzukommen
angesichts einer sehr starken wirtschaft
und natürlich auch eine sehr robusten
und starken sozialstaat uns
möglichkeiten verschafft gerade was das
gesundheitswesen betrifft die
anderenorts nicht in gleicher weise zur
verfügung stehen aber auch für uns gilt
wenn sich alles ändert ändert sich eben
viel im leben für diejenigen die
arbeiten gehen wollen und ihre
arbeitsplätze nicht mehr wie gewohnt
wahrnehmen können für die unternehmen
die planen was mit ihrer eigenen zukunft
weiter sein wird aber auch im
alltagsleben aller bürgerinnen und
bürger die ihre freundin nicht mehr
sehen können wie bisher die viele
gewohnte veranstaltungen und lebens
praktiken nicht mehr fortsetzen können
ich finde dass wir den bürgern und
bürger dieses landes sehr dankbar sein
können für das was sie leisten denn die
eigentliche beobachtung die wir machen
können ist doch dass es eine großes
einvernehmen gibt mit der notwendigkeit
auch drastische maßnahmen zu ergreifen
und das ist eine große coup haid und
besonnenheit gibt auf die wir als
diejenigen die mit einem
regierungsauftrag versehen sind auch
zählen können
genauso wie die parlamente was wir
natürlich auch in einer solchen
situation ist geschlossenheit
es ist deshalb sehr gut dass die
regierung in dieser frage sehr eng und
gut zusammen arbeitet und es sehr gut
dass diese geschlossenheit auch gilt im
verhältnis zwischen bund und ländern
gern wird ja geklagt oder die
beschwerlichkeiten des föderalismus ich
will die klage in die nicht einstimmen
was meint er sich dass es genau
umgekehrt
die tatsache dass wir jetzt sehr
sorgfältig noch viele
stunden nicht nur heute sondern auch die
letzten tage diskutiert haben über das
was jetzt zu machen es und dass wir in
der regierung einen vorschlag entwickeln
konnten der dann am ende auch für alle
länder funktioniert hat ist eigentlich
etwas das dazu beiträgt dass unsere
entscheidungs vorschläge miteinander
besser werden und dass wir miteinander
das land besser regieren können was in
dieser situation ganz besonders wichtig
ist geschlossenheit ist also auch etwas
was man braucht was es aber eben gibt
und für die regierung wie für uns alle
gemeinsam gilt was wir brauchen es
augenmaß um zuversicht um in dieser
situation besonnen zu handeln und
jeweils abzuwägen was der mögliche
nächste schritt ist der die erreichten
erfolge nicht gefährlich ich glaube dass
setzt sehr viel selbstkritische
reflexionen voraus wir müssen immer
fragen hat das gestimmt was wir gemacht
haben
auch bereit sein entscheidung zu
korrigieren falls das notwendig ist und
nicht aus falschen gründen hat etwas
festzuhalten dass sich nicht bewährt hat
aber in diesem sinne mit augenmaß und
zuversicht können wir jetzt auch
veränderungen vornehmen die mit den
beschlüssen die die ministerpräsidenten
und die regierung heute gemeinsam
gefasst haben auch verbunden sind
wir eröffnen stückweise anteil des
sozialen lebens und auch der
wirtschaftlichen tätigkeit weil wir
glauben dass könnte genau das maß sein
was jetzt möglich ist ohne die erfolge
zu gefährden
und das ist ein richtiger ein wichtiger
schritt der jetzt gebraucht wird für das
worum es eigentlich geht wir bewegen uns
in eine neue normalität eine normalität
die nicht kurz sein wird sondern die
längere zeit anhalten wird bis es uns
gelungen wird bessere therapeutische
möglichkeiten zu haben und auch
impfstoffe zu besitzen die uns helfen
die ausbreitung der pandemie in
deutschland und andernorts zu verhindern
solange das nicht der fall ist wird es
eine lange zeit geben in der wir unsere
wirtschaftliche praxis unsere soziale
praxis so verändert haben müssen dass
wir mit dem virus und mit seinen
auswirkungen mit dem infektionsgeschehen
trotzdem ein gutes leben miteinander
haben
weil das gut gelingt mit den bürgerinnen
und bürgern und weil sie klug und
besonnen sind weil wir alle gemeinsam
augen
zum zuversicht haben können wir glaube
ich davon ausgehen dass wir eine chance
haben das zu schaffen und das wäre ja
nicht schlecht weil es ja auch eine zeit
da nachgeben muss in der wir dann auf
dieser erfahrung zurückgreifen können
und eine weitere zukunft bilden können
wir kommen zu ihren fragen die erste von
jörg blank von der dpa frau
bundeskanzlerin gaststätten restaurants
und hotels bleiben erstmal geschlossen
die bürger sind zu hause geblieben
weitgehend über ostern im mai kingston
können sie da vielleicht einen
silberstreif am horizont sehen auch für
die menschen was pfingsten angeht und
muss man möglicherweise für das
gastronomie und den tourismusbereich die
hilfen noch einmal aufstocken und herr
ministerpräsident söder eine frage
können sie uns bitte erklären warum man
gerade die 800 quadratmeter gewählt hat
und nicht vielleicht 600 oder 1200 das
ist ja eine wichtige frage
danke also zu der frage was passiert mit
gastronomie restaurants und ähnlichen
können wir heute noch nicht sagen wir
gehen jetzt in kleineren schritten voran
und wir müssen schauen wie sich das
auswirkt wir haben nach wie vor an die
menschen die aufforderung außerhalb des
eigenen hausstandes nur mit einer
einzigen person als sich außerhalb des
haushalts aufzuhalten und sie können
sich vielleicht vorstellen bei
gaststätten gastronomie ist es überhaupt
nicht mehr kontrollierbar wer um einen
tisch herum sitzen und deshalb müssen
wir hier schon darauf achten dass wir
sozusagen die maßstäbe nicht vollkommen
verschieben also das ist noch nicht dran
und wir müssen jetzt erst mal gucken ob
wir mit den schritten die wir jetzt
gehen öffnung anderer geschäfte
abschlussklassen
abitur oder in der zehn klassen prüfung
oder den hauptschulen ob wir mit diesen
maßnahmen sozusagen unseren spielraum
ausschöpfen oder nicht was sich dann tut
das sehen wir erst in 14 tagen bis drei
wochen und dann werden wir über weitere
schritte beraten je nachdem wie sich die
dinge entwickeln und wir müssen halt
auch genauer werden jetzt noch mal
wiederholen indem nachverfolgen der
infektionsketten und dass deshalb stand
das heute nicht auf der tagesordnung und
deshalb wäre es auch vollkommen
spekulativ sich jetzt dazu zu äußern und
zu einer philosophie noch zu der markus
söder gleich noch etwas sagt mit den
quadratmetern
es geht ja nicht darum dass ein
unternehmen oder ein laden nicht ein
inneres schutzkonzept machen könnte was
uns noch geleitet dass das für das für
den einzelhandel kann das wahrscheinlich
jeder was wir schauen müssen ist dass
wir nicht die gesamte den gesamten
publikumsverkehr in den städten wieder
vollkommen möglich machen weil dann auch
wieder infektionsketten entstehen
sondern dass man das dosiert macht und
da gab es durchaus eine breite
diskussion darüber und im wege eines
kompromisses hat man sich jetzt auf
diese zahl geeinigt aber die ist nicht
wesentlich dadurch dass man sagt mit
1000 quadratmetern kann einer kein
schutzkonzept machen sondern sie ist mit
der frage verbunden wie viel leben sind
das dann und was bedeutet dass auch an
öffentlichen personennahverkehr und
allein was darum liegt dank an das
nochmal ergänzen beide bereiche es kommt
darauf an unkontrollierte situationen so
weit es geht zu unterbinden
die menschen haben sich jetzt zu
unglaublich geduldig fallenden
verständnisvoll und zwar in
unterschiedlichen regionen mit
unterschiedlicher infektions situation
das war noch mal ein großes kompliment
ist die menschen haben sich da auch
jetzt über ostern glaube ich insgesamt
sehr gut daran gehalten das ist ein sehr
positiver wert wenn wir jetzt her gehen
und überlegen bei ich verstehe dass
gerade login lokal zum essen zu gehen
dass das eigentlich das was man gern
machen möchte oder dass der eine gerne
bei uns in gerne bier kaufen möchte oder
in andere außengastronomie
wir würden damit aber
zum jetzigen zeitung erheblichste
risiken eingehen
man kann in der gastronomie per se schon
keinen mundschutz beispielsweise
organisieren oder dort wo es dann
vielleicht auch die chance gibt ein glas
wein oder bier zu nehmen
da wird die disziplin automatisch
welcher darum ist der teil der jenige
der er am entferntesten erstmal an steht
das zweite bei den acht und in der tat
im bundeskonzert völlig recht es gab da
etwas unterschiedliche überlegungen die
einen haben gemeint es ist völlig klar
wir machen keine größenordnung machen
und schon quasi alles auf versuchen aber
ein schutzkonzept zu hinterlegen
das problem ist eben einfach dass es
damit zu wahnsinnigen ansammlungen gibt
bei den großen den ganz großen
möbelhäusern den ganz großen
unternehmungen die sicherlich alles tun
würden um zu versuchen das zu
organisieren aber wir führen dazu dass
wir dann in den innenstädten wieder eine
so massive ballung haben dass der ganze
positive effekt der letzten wochen in
wenigen in wenigen tagen sich aufheben
lese und das wollte man nicht riskieren
und darum ist das ein in der tat
kompromiss da gibt es eine baurechtliche
vorschriften wieder als anhaltspunkt
kalt ich persönlich halte 800 auch fast
alex hat für zu viel
wir haben das ding auch eingestehen die
länder können das machen können das
ausschöpfen
wir haben in bayern beispielsweise an
der kabinette überprüfen das war sie
auch in der bin ich bin ja dankbar die
länder gesagt haben also in einigen
bundesländern ist weniger an problematik
als in anderen und die eine stärkere
herausforderung haben müssen natürlich
noch vorsichtig und umsichtig agieren
das wollen wir dann heute nochmal auch
morgen in den jeweiligen
landesregierungen dann haben wir
gewichten aber ich glaube der komponist
gut vertretbar
den kann man so umsetzen und ich freue
mich jedenfalls dass insgesamt sich die
vorsichtigere linie auch die
bundesgrenzen vertreten hat und jeder
change oder scholz auch mit ganz
entwickelt haben dass die sich ganz
mehrheitlich durchsetzt die nächste
frage herr schmidt vielleicht können wir
das personal ist bei einer frage
belassen im interesse ihrer kollegen
frau bundeskanzlerin anfangs hieß es ja
flecken bekämpft das stand über allem
was ist eigentlich die derzeitige
strategie im umgang mit der pandemie
wenn man so darüber schreiben würde also
has kipping begriff auf welchem level
oder wollen wir noch weiter gehen alle
neuinfektionen so weit runter fahren
das für die infektionsketten immer
gleich zurückverfolgen können also
worauf läuft es ja gerade eigentlich
hinaus was es da die strategie und
welche kriterien sind entscheidend wenn
es dann um weitere lockerungen gehen
würde na ja also wir sind jetzt in einem
bereich der neuinfektionen
die jetzt in den letzten tagen so um
3000 oder sogar darunter lag die kann
man natürlich in den vielen
gesundheitsämtern durchaus wenn man wenn
die gut ausgestattet sind nachvollziehen
das ist nicht mehr so dass das überhaupt
nicht geht und das muss auch unser ziel
sein
alles andere wird uns in große große
schwierigkeiten bringen das wird auch
vielleicht nicht gleich von der ersten
woche an klappen aber wir werden das
jetzt sehr viel genauer anschauen das
infektionsschutzgesetz sagt nicht nur
dass ein gesundheitsamt die zahl der
fälle melden muss sondern ein
gesundheitsamt muss eigentlich melden
sind das menschen in welchem alter an
welcher stelle in welchem ort des
bereichs des gesundheitsamtes und wenn
sie dann sehen sie haben einen
infektionsfall in einem altersheim oder
sie haben etwas in einer berufssituation
oder an einer schule dann können sie
natürlich ganz anders vorgehen und auch
die schutzmaßnahmen ganz anders machen
und da müssen wir hinkommen also die
kurve ist flacher geworden ist bleibt
nach wie vor so sie muss so sein dass
sie unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überfordert und wir haben modell
betrachtungen gemacht wenn wir sind
jetzt ungefähr bei diesem reproduktions
faktor 1 also einer steckt einen an der
natürlich auch nicht das kann immer nur
für eine infektionskette sagen ob eine
einen ansteckt und das ist dann ein
mittelwert aber es ist ungefähr einer
steckt ein an
schon wenn wir darauf kommen dass jeder
1,1 menschen ansteckt dann sind wir im
oktober wieder an der leistungsfähigkeit
unseres gesundheitssystems mit den
angenommenen intensivbetten wenn wir 12
also jeder steckt 20 prozent mehr 1,2 an
also von fünf menschen steckt einer 2 1
und 4 1
dann kommen wir im juli schon an die
belastungsgrenze unseres
gesundheitssystems bei 1,3 das hört sich
nicht viel wir kommen von 45
ansteckungen drei bis fünf ansteckungen
1,3 sind wir im juni an der
belastungsgrenze unseres
gesundheitssystems daran sehen sie also
in welch kleinen spielraum
wir uns aufhalten und die ganze
entwicklung basiert darauf dass wir
davon ausgehen dass wir eine
infektionszahlen haben die wir
überblicken können die wir nachverfolgen
können und dass wir mehr schutzkonzepte
haben und durch die mehr schutzkonzepte
auch mehr lockerungen machen können aber
es ist ein dünnes eis wie hat ja gesagt
hat oder eine fragile situation oder ein
wirklich eine situation in der vorsicht
das geburt ist und nicht über mut ganz
draußen r tide von wild ich habe eine
frage zu dem masten gebot
herr söder sprach von community masken
frau bundeskanzlerin sie sprachen von
alters masken sind dass die masken die
die leute tragen sollen von denen sie
noch im vierten april gesagt haben dass
sie zu wehren schleudern werden können
und dass man die nicht tragen soll
und noch eine frage zum nordrhein
westfalen nordrhein westfalen hat
gestern angekündigt dass man auch die
vorschulen unter umständen öffnen will
zieht nordrhein westfalen mit oder macht
nordrhein westfalen am montag schulen
schon auf teilweise und auch die
vorschulen bezüglich der schulen gesagt
worden dass man die letzte klasse der
grundschule gegebenenfalls ab viertem
öffnen kann das mit werden die länder
auch in gewisser abstufung handhaben da
gibt es auch etwas unterschiedliche
meinung dazu aber das ist eine der
optionen aber nicht sofort und ab montag
sondern sofort bei den entsprechenden
vorbereitungen die abiturklassen diab
schulklassen wie bitte
ja ich sage ihnen das was wir heute
beschlossen haben und dann gibt es ja
auch der ministerpräsident von nrw den
kann man ja auch fragen auf jeden fall
kann ich nur sagen was wir heute
beschlossen haben so zweitens ich habe
darauf hingewiesen und das steht auch
hier glaube ich heute wieder in den text
dass die behandlung der community masten
sachgerecht zu erfolgen hat das ganz
wichtig sie müssen regelmäßig gewaschen
werden beziehungsweise gebügelt in den
backofen gelegt oder in der mikrowelle
auch wenn sich das etwas sozusagen aus
fröhlich anhört aber das sind die
patentrezepte mit denen man es wird es
halt tschentscher der schon so war auf
der hut als ich sagen können ansonsten
sind sie nicht produktiv im sinne des
schutzes für andere und sie müssen auch
häufiger gewechselt werden und das wird
eine wichtige aufgabe seite wechseln die
seite frau pd
ja eine frage frau bundeskanzlerin sie
haben davon gesprochen wir werden damit
leben müssen bis es medikamente oder
eine neben stoff gibt und auch herr
tschentscher die haben gesagt das wird
uns über mehrere monate noch begleiten
diese pandemie wenn sie schon jetzt so
weit in die zukunft blicken reden sie
dann auch über konzepte die von manchen
zum beispiel dem deutschen ethikrat
diskutiert wurden dass man auf längere
sicht besondere schutzkonzepte für
fohlen wohlrabe variable gruppen
entwickelt die ermöglichen dass man
anderen nicht wo in arabien mehr
freiheiten gibt ist das etwas worüber
sie reden oder ist das für sie absolut
tabu
und ich habe auch noch eine kurze zweite
frage gezielt auf die gottesdienste wenn
die läden öffnen warum ist es dann
unverantwortlich ein gottesdienst
zuzulassen ich habe das gefühl in der
kirche am sonntag sitzen manchmal
weniger leute als an einem
bekleidungsgeschäft unterwegs sind ja
auch die geschäfte werden natürlich
diesen maßnahmen ergreifen müssen das
werden auch die kirchen tun
wir sagen ja auch nicht dass wir wir
reden jetzt über die zeit bis zum
dritten mal wir wollen mit den
gesprächen jetzt in ein gespräch
eintreten wie das gemacht werden kann
die gegebenheiten sind sehr
unterschiedlich zwischen einer kleinen
dorfkirche und einer großen krise wie
dem kölner dom oder
großen kirchen in hamburg vielleicht und
insofern muss das sehr gut abgewogen
werden aber wir haben in unserem
beschlussfassung wenn sie das heute
lesen sehr deutlich zum ausdruck
gebracht dass das wir mit den kirchen
dieses gespräch suchen wollen
und manche länder haben das auch jetzt
schon sehr stark gemacht alle länder
waren mit den kirchen in kontakt und
insofern wissen wir dass wir hier
gemeinsame lösungen finden dass ich ihre
frage nach dem langen zeitraum war
ach so ja wir sagen ja natürlich für
wilde gruppen insbesondere für pflegende
senioren und behinderteneinrichtungen
müssen nach den lokalen gegebenheiten
gemacht werden wir machen nicht so das
war es ja manchmal diskutiert wird die
jungen kriegen alle freiheiten und die
älteren werden ins abseits gestellt das
halten wir nicht für ethisch vertretbar
aber natürlich müssen gruppen die
anfälliger sind für infektionen mit
besonderen schutz konzepten gedacht
werden wir wollen sie aber gerade nicht
sozial ausschließen das ist hier dass
das nicht zu einer vollständigen
sozialen isolation führt das ist unser
maßstab und leben aus stadt muss
individuell damit werden haring
bundeskanzler ich würde ganz gerne noch
mal nachfragen zur einheitlichkeit der
beschlüsse der hat ja eben schon
angedeutet dass bayern ein paar
beschlüsse etwas später umsetzt oder in
etwas anderer form also wo fürchten sie
werden doch differenzen auftreten etwa
den grenzgebieten weil sie natürlich
auch einen druck dadurch entsteht dass
bestimmte eu nachbarländer ganz andere
schlüsse fällen dänemark und österreich
öffnen mehr frankreich ist verschlossen
ist das heute diskutiert worden
und warum hat man die maske eigentlich
nicht verpflichtend gemacht sie haben
beide jetzt von einem gebot gesprochen
also ich finde es nicht städte wie es
fair gegenüber den anderen journalisten
wenn sie immer zwei drei fragen stellen
das bezieht sich auf die differenz
zwischen den bundesländern und den
kommunen jena hat ja schon ein mehr als
ein gebot sondern einer anordnung ist
dass diskutiert worden dass wir nicht
doch am ende wieder ein flickenteppich
haben wir müssen ja das was wir fordern
von den bürgerinnen und bürgern auch
wirklich umsetzen können und wir sind
schrittweise jetzt mit den community
masken oder alltags massen ja weiter
gegangen das haben sie ja auch erlebt
und in je mehr die vorhanden sein werden
um so mehr wird man vielleicht auch
darüber reden ob es dann noch weitere
schritte der der dringlichkeit gibt aber
jetzt erst einmal sagen wir der solche
maske hat und wer das erhalten kann und
die sind ja jeden tag besser erhältlich
der soll sie auch benutzen dass es also
dass die wirkung des gebots das ist
stärker als das wir das vor ein paar
wochen gemacht haben und jetzt werde man
auch sehen wie die entwicklung dort
weitergeht jetzt habe ich ihre erst auch
so schauen sie vielleicht kann herr
söder was dazu sagen ich habe noch nicht
gehört dass es zu verwerfungen zwischen
bundesländer jetzt geführt hat weil er
einem baumarkt auf hatte und der andere
nicht
aber es ist vielleicht können dass die
länder mal sagen wie sie das sehen weil
sie das ja auch ich bin mit der
einheitlichkeit zufrieden sie werden in
einem föderalen gebilde nie auf den tag
genau das gleiche haben manche haben
sommerferien im august die können bei
der abiturprüfung noch mal anders
rangehen als der juni mit seinen
sommerferien beginnt aber vom geist von
dem ganzen drangehen haben wir eines
hohes maß an einheitlichkeit erreicht
was für einen föderalen staat schon fast
an ein wunder grenzt dass er zumindest
gewünscht ist also zum einen weil es so
ein unterschiedliches
infektionsgeschehen ich persönlich bin
zum beispiel ländern die ein sehr
geringes infektionsgeschehen haben oder
geringe sehr dankbar dass sie nahezu
alle maßnahmen genauso mittragen
die den gebieten die besonders stark
betroffen sind wie bayern baden
amberg nordrhein westfalen
beispielsweise das dann dass der große
solidarität herrscht auch in anderen
regionen dass man da noch mal nicht
außen anders macht hängt von der jeweils
örtlichen situation habe es ist dann mal
eine woche mehr oder eine woche weniger
oder paar quadratmeter mehr oder weniger
das ist aber im grunde genommen nicht
entscheiden sie hatten beispielsweise
ausgangs beschränkungen nicht
kontaktsperre aber die leute haben sich
an alles gehalten und das bringt ist das
positiv ich glaube dass der föderalismus
sich im moment als sehr leistungsfähig
erweist weil der große vorteil gegenüber
dem reinen zentralistischen staat ist
beim zentralistischen staat wird zwar
schnell etwas einheitliches verordnet
aber für die umsetzung wird sehr schwer
gesagt wir haben es jetzt geschafft und
es sind zwar manche diskussionen die wir
führen aber die mühe ist es wert bewegen
dabei auch die argumente untereinander
sehr gut glaube ich kann das sagen
kommen aber zu einem sehr sehr guten
text ergebnis unter umsetzung und die
länder garantieren hat die bessere
umsetzung vor ort weil sie uns näher
sind und da das ergibt sich dann
insgesamt aus meiner sicht wesentlich
höhere leistungsfähigkeit das kann man
beispielsweise auch sehr gut an dem
gesundheitssystem erkennen dass ja auch
sehr föderal organisiert ist das zeigt
sich an der stelle im vergleich zu
vielen anderen ländern doch als sehr
sehr widerstandsfähig nicht geändert wir
haben der erfolg der letzten wochen gibt
uns ja recht wir haben unterschiedliche
wege gefunden den ländern die
rechtsverordnung sind sehr
unterschiedlich von der von der von der
konstruktion aber im ergebnis kommt es
dann doch sehr weitgehend alles aufs
gleiche aufs gleiche hinaus
und wir haben ja in deutschland dadurch
jetzt doch sehr schnell und insgesamt
das infektionsgeschehen verlangsamt also
dass es regionale bisschen
unterschiedlich weil es eben auch
unterschiedliche ausgangssituationen gab
aber wenn sie sich mal die daten des
robert-koch-instituts angehen die dieser
faktor die verdoppelung zeit wird zu
anfang beobachtet haben die sind eben
deutlich in ganz deutschland in allen
ländern zurückgegangen
etwas unterschiedlich was an der
ausgangssituation nach aber im grunde
gibt uns der erfolg der letzten wochen
ja recht dass wir in diesem prinzip
einen einheitlichen maßstab zu haben
über denen dann keiner hinausgeht aber
den man durchaus noch strenger ausführen
kann gibt uns im grunde grunde recht und
insofern bin ich sicher dass wir auch
dieses konzept was für heute entworfen
haben dann weitestgehend einheitliche in
deutschland auch umsetzen können
wir können noch zwei fragen nehmen das
wäre
herfried frau bundeskanzlerin wann kommt
die tracking & tracing ob und warum
dauert das so lange und sportstätten für
individualsportarten ihre nachbarn in
österreich macht es jetzt für
speerwerfer guten stone hat also die
sportstätten auf und war ein
geisterspiel in der bundesliga ein thema
zu dem zulässigen app kann ich folgendes
sagen sie muss ja praktisch vom robert
koch institut für gut befunden seien vom
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik und natürlich auch
von dem datenschutzbeauftragten
dort wird natürlich darauf geachtet dass
insbesondere auch keine anfälligkeit von
bestimmten baustein dieser app da ist
und wir müssen auch sicherstellen dass
wir sie anwenden können auf den
verschiedenen sorten von smartphones da
muss man also auch mit den
betriebssystemen herstellern in kontakt
sein
das alles nimmt zeit in anspruch aber es
wird mit hochdruck an den dingen
gearbeitet
das erste ist wir haben überlegt und es
wurde auch diskutiert ob man bei sport
etwas machen soll
ob man bei kunst und kultureinrichtungen
es machen soll wir haben uns jetzt
entschieden das erst in einem zweiten
schritt beim nächsten mal zu diskutieren
einfach deswegen weil man nicht
vergessen darf für lockern ohnehin an
einigen stellen deutlich und wir wollen
jetzt das gesundheitssystem auch nicht
überstrapazieren wir halten das was
jetzt gemacht wird insgesamt für sehr
vertretbar
wir haben keine weiteren einschränkungen
beschlossen das übrigens wichtig auch
noch einmal fest seien keine
einschränkungen sondern einstellen
erleichtere aber alle die anderen fragen
sowie österreich und anderer kultur
fragen werden an einem zweiten schritt
entschieden
das gleiche gilt also bundesliga woche
kein thema die liga selber überlegt ja
und arbeitet der sicherheitskonzepte und
wird dann sicherlich wird sicherlich
dann demnächst ein thema sein darüber zu
reden ob in welcher form
geisterspiele möglich sind das wird man
diskutieren kann die letzte frage von
frau kunz
frau bundeskanzlerin und herr
ministerpräsident wieder hat es im kreis
der ministerpräsidenten kollegen gegeben
die vor einer vor einem grossen schaden
der wirtschaft gewarnt haben wenn man
jetzt nicht früher lockert und wann wird
die nächste überprüfung dieser maßnahmen
die sie heute beschlossen haben sein
es war ja schon mal auch von diesen
sonntag die rede dass es da noch meine
zusammenkunft gibt dann ist die nächste
9 an diesem sonntag gibt es keine
zusammenkunft da laufen die maßnahmen
aus aber wir müssen ja rechtzeitig
vorher die beschlüsse fassen damit dass
dann auch umgesetzt werden kann ich habe
ja erst gesagt wir wollen unseren 30 04
wieder treffen im virtuellen raum und
werden dann darüber debattieren was gilt
nach dem dritten mai denn die
allgemeinverfügung oder wie auch immer
die verordnung der länder heißen werden
jetzt ja bis zum dritten mai aufgelegt
was jetzt schon absehbar ist dass wir
natürlich immer gucken müssen können wir
eine maßnahme schon in einem 14 tägigen
rhythmus beobachten deshalb ja auch der
14 tägige ansatz also wer sich sozusagen
unter einer wenn jetzt die lockerungen
eintreten dann sieht man ja ob es mehr
infektionsgeschehen gibt es dauert dann
eine ganze weile ingo inkubationszeit
dann der test dann dem mitteilung als
robert koch institut das heißt sie sehen
im grunde erst 10 12 eigentlich 14 tagen
hat die maßnahme etwas bewirkt im blick
aufs infektionsgeschehen war ist alles
so geblieben wie es war
und wir haben jetzt bei den drei wochen
gesehen dass es doch ganz schön
schwerfällig ist bis ich die kurve mal
dann in die richtige richtung bewegt wir
haben es eigentlich sehr schön gesehen
bei dem verdopplung zeiten
wir haben es jetzt in den letzten tagen
gesehen dass wir immer weniger neu
angesteckt hatten als gesunde das war ja
auch eine gute nachricht
und wir können jetzt sind jetzt bei
diesem faktor schon in einem bereich für
den reproduktions faktor der hat ja auch
immer fehlergrenzen wo man eben auch
sagte da kann man über lockerungen
überhaupt nachdenken und
insofern tritt das also am 30.4
sein bild blickt auf das was dann ab 4
märz gilt und es gab schon ein großes
gemeinsames gefühl da sind die börsen
bisschen unterschiedlich ich finde das
nicht aber auch in der natur der
verantwortlichkeiten der gegebenheiten
und der sache wenn wir alle gleich wären
dann würden wir sie überhaupt nicht mehr
erfreuen
journalistisch und insofern leben wir
auch von dem hohen gut der
verschiedenartigkeit die uns dann immer
wieder zu kompromissen führt wir haben
auch in der bundesregierung auf
diskutiert und zum schluss gute
kompromisse gefunden und das ist das was
trägt und was eine schöne erfahrung
dann kann alle noch der hinweis wir
haben die beschlüsse also zwei kurze
punkten einig weil ich es auch jetzt
noch weiter die haben wir zu den schulen
ganz kurz war sondern zu der frage wer
kümmert sich mehr um wirtschaft und wer
weniger die eine frage was sagen will
also wir waren die nächste woche
wirklich brauchen damit die schulen sich
vorbereiten können
die lehrerverbände haben wir
ausdrücklich gebeten nichts überstürzen
das sollten auch unsere lehrer hören das
heißt ab dem 27
können dann prüfungsvorbereitung die
abitur und mittlere reife ähnliches
stattfinden und wir würden einen vierten
sondern 11 mai mit den anderen
abschlussklassen überlegen wie man das
organisieren kann
grundschulen und kitas bleiben dann erst
einmal zu mit entsprechend
notfallbetreuung aber jetzt sowas zu den
themen wirtschaft ich kenne keinen
einzigen minister werden keinen einzigen
und kein mitglied der bundesregierung
das nicht bei dem thema corona genau
zwei herausforderungen kopf hat die
gesundheit und die wirtschaft und da
gibt es niemanden der nicht in gleicher
weise beides absolut als top priorität
einschätzt beides müssen wir im blick
hat
der bund hat meiner überzeugung nach
wenn ich das sagen darf ein exzellentes
in europa einmaliges wirtschaftsprogramm
vorgelegt und bei uns war sogar stolz im
bayerischen kabinett was noch nie der
fall
das seien also ein bundesfinanzminister
und schon gleich gar keiner von der spd
da war es war ein hoch qualifiziertes
und hervorragendes gespräch und nahtlose
übereinstimmung
das heißt ich halte jede form von detail
wettbewerb im sinne von wer ist jetzt
der wirtschaftsfreundlichere wer ist
mehr der medizinische in der jetzigen
situation nicht dass er unter uns auch
so seiner für unangebracht jeder tut an
seiner stelle das beste was er kann
jeder will dass die wirtschaft
erfolgreich ist jeder möchte so viel
freiheit wie möglich natürlich aber
jeder weiß auch um die herausforderung
und also gerade wenn ich die mitglieder
der bundesliga anstatt in
internationalen vergleichen oder auch
länder die direkt an